par monsieur bonsoir le ministre des
finances du nouveau gouvernement du
québec monsieur yves séguin a donc
présenté cet après-midi un budget c'est
avec tristesse que nous avons appris le
décès hier après-midi de claude
beauchamp qui a créé et animé l'émission
capital actions sur nos ondes de 1995 à
2004 il avait 80 ans
on ne connaît pas la cause de son décès
kurt busch ans est reconnu comme un
pionnier du journalisme économique au
québec qu'il a mis sur pied la section
économique du journal la presse et du
soleil de québec où il a été rédacteur
en chef et éditeur adjoint
il a aussi été actionnaire d affaires
qui l'a relancé comme tabloïd
il a été président de la fédération
professionnelle des journalistes il a
contribué à la fondation du conseil de
presse
et il a été tenté aussi par la politique
à un moment de sa vie en étant candidat
à la mairie de montréal surtout été le
premier ministre du québec françois
legault a offert ses condoléances à sa
fille dominé qui a toute sa famille
ajoutant qu'il a été un des premiers
vulgarisateur de l'économie du québec au
nom de toute l'équipe de rdi économie et
du service de l'information de
radio-canada nous offrons nos
condoléances à la famille de claude
beauchamp avec nous jean paul gagné
éditeur émérite des publications les
affaires et michèle boisvert délégué
général du québec à paris qui a
longtemps travaillé avec claude
beauchamp à vous deux bons soirs comme
ça franchement gérald merci merci d'être
avec nous à cette journée triste quand
même jean paul gagné claude beauchamp a
vraiment consacré comme vous sa vie
professionnelle au journalisme
économique par des noues un peu de
l'importance de claude beauchamp pour le
journalisme économique
ben moi je pense que 2000 qu'on peut
retenir c'est un inspirateur économique
au québec c'est lui qui a créé comme
vous avez dit tout à l'heure la section
économique de la presse à ce moment en a
dans les quotidiens québécois il y avait
deux ou trois journalistes financiers
qui faisait essentiellement des
nouvelles
m financière alors claude a battu une
sélection de dix à douze journalistes à
la presse
il était un grand en spirale des
inspirateurs pour ce personnage
certainement parce que ces personnes
arrivées d'autres sections de la presse
alors ils ont vu que vers la direction
de la section de la presse quelqu'un qui
est inspirant quelqu'un qui avait un
certain charisme aussi un bon
vulgarisateur un bon journaliste
un gars très très intelligente et
ensuite ils passent au soleil il y a de
fait la même chose au soleil avec une
section un peu moins bien entendu que
j'ai dirigés ou soleil à l'époque
alors quand l'odeur il est passé aux
affaires comme un co actionnaire
effectivement bon il a voulu que je
viens avec lui qu'on rédacteur en chef
et il a vraiment bâti les affaires
rebâti les enfants parce qu'à l'époque
au début des années 80 des affaires
avait un tirage à peu près 25 mille
abonnés n'était pas kiosque ne vais pas
de couleurs est un journal très sombre
en quelque sorte et sobre aussi après sa
brutale et bâtir dis donc c'est un
bassin c'est respirateurs pour les
journalistes pour le juriste reconnu
qu'au québec
deux générations de journalistes et il
était aussi en bas de ça parce que
rebâti les affaires et puis a été je
pense aussi la cheville ouvrière de
capital actions est dit absolument
michel boisvert d'ailleurs vous avez
travaillé à capital-actions vous avez
travaillé ici à radio canada avec claude
parlez nous du journaliste de l'homme
que vous avez côtoyé
c'est un homme ne lui doivent beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
il était d'une très très grande rigueur
avait un grand respect pour le
journalisme économique et pour les
entrepreneurs
donc c'est quelqu'un qui répondent à
toutes mes questions pro visait les
textes me disais à quel point c'est
important d'avoir les chiffres corrects
parce que on pouvait causer tellement
tort à des entrepreneurs si les chiffres
n'étaient pas les bons combien de fois
ils me disaient avez-vous à pied il faut
toujours vérifier
même si c'est écrit dans le communiqué
appelé il m'a écouté la rigueur
c'est grâce à lui que j'ai pu rencontrer
la majorité des grands entrepreneurs du
québec capital-actions vous le savez on
recevait tous les jours un chroniqueur
est un homme d'affaires et qu'elle a par
le dirigeant claude volet toujours le
dirigeant
et les gens disaient oui parce qu'il
respectait claude beauchaud plus besoin
était un tel monument en école en
informations économiques que les gens
d'affaires veut n'est parce que c'était
claude beauchamp qui était à la barre
est vraiment construit quelque chose
vraiment capital actions à fait comme on
le voit gérald et il a réussi justement
à vulgariser cette information la police
est tellement important de donner des
outils aux québécois pour qu'ils
s'approprient cette information
économique mais saint sans en perdre la
rigueur
sincèrement c'est un homme d'une rigueur
incroyable et extrêmement généreuse
autrement vous parler de cette rigueur
de ses appels de la vérification des
chiffres monique dumont qui a été
recherchiste longtemps ici à
radio-canada en quête et à
capital-actions me parlait justement peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui de cette rigueur de
kurt busch a et de l'importance de
questionner de questionner toujours les
chiffres
parlez-moi de son importance dans
l'éducation financière des québécois
jean paul gagné mais moi comme geste
juste lancée puis quelqu'un d'inspirant
il c'était quelqu'un aussi que je dirais
qu'à donner une crédibilité aux
journalistes
et quand même au journalisme économique
au québec jean-luc économique et
financier parce qu'à une certaine époque
que certaines sections délaissé dans les
journaux les sections générales la
politique faits divers horizons
s'étaient prévalus risée dans les
journaux mais dans les dents dans le
monde de l'économie les pages
économiques des journaux c'était des
pages de bourse avec quelques nouvelles
financières autour des colonnes de
bourse s'est peu à peu près sans une
personne n'avait l'air à s'intéresser à
ça dans les journaux de l'époque radio
canada faisait absolument rien du côté
de l'information financière et
économique
donc il fallait quelqu'un qu'avait qu'il
est capable d'inspirer qui avait un
charisme qui pouvait donner de la
crédibilité à ces à cette section là
cette section qui des minus
la presse lors ce qui est arrivé je
pense que c'est ça sa grande
contribution appréciable sa crédibilité
le fait qu'il a participé à de
nombreuses émissions de radio et de télé
à l'époque pendant toute sa vie il est
un très très grand communicateur il y
avait des conférences aussi un
conférencier très habile recherché à
l'époque il était puis s'est impliqué
dans toutes sortes d'organisations en
politique comme bénévole oui ben
politique il ya un moment donné il a été
approché pour lancer un parti politique
à montréal
et puis bon je donne façon d'un autre je
pense que il a fait une alliance avec
eux
monsieur pierre books il me souvient
bien raisonnable et deux parties ont été
fusionnées claude guibert - c'est pas
pour moi
il a été aussi sollicitée bien entendu
par le parti libéral du québec pour se
présenter dans une course à la chefferie
il y a reculé aussi je pense qu'ils les
rapports nécessairement un grand intérêt
pour la politique mais il se faisait
sollicité énormément et moi je sais il a
été sollicité les gens dit claude claude
votre body body y est un clown
ben oui claude avait de la crédibilité
il y avait une capacité de communication
exceptionnel et pour un parti politique
je pense que c'est extrêmement attrayant
sur les cinq derniers mois michel robert
si vous permettez michel boisvert en
terminant vous l'avez connu à une époque
importante sur le plan économique les
grands d'année nortel la bulle
technologique notamment
on a vécu des grands grands moments tous
les deux c'était comme vous le dites
qu'est la bulle technologique c'étaient
les premières acquisitions de couche car
on a vu monter couche tard la même chose
avec cgi
c'était la grande folie des fusions
acquisitions vous rappeler les premiers
temps des synergies et effectivement la
dégringolade de nortel le scandale
bréxent mon dieu c'était une période
passionnante suivant c'était pour moi de
très très grand moment dans ma carrière
et je l' ai dit tout à l'heure et je le
redis je dois beaucoup beaucoup à claude
beauchamp et j'en remercie permis si je
lui ai déjà dit ici et je vais encore
lyon ii ce soir et ben je veux
transmettre toutes mes condoléances
aussi à la famille à dominique avec qui
j'ai travaillé parce que dominique était
à capitale
sion avec sa femme céline qui venait et
tous les autres membres de sa famille
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
important qu'on gagne pain jean paul
gagné michel boisvert merci d'avoir
rendu hommage à claude beauchamp ce soir
merci beaucoup merci merci